foreign
what's up Catherine
hi John I'm George thank you for taking
my call uh one question
um my husband and I have been out of
work since September last year and um we
it's getting a little tight right now
and so we called our creditors to um be
proactive and ask them to can we be on a
program paying less over a period of
time we've had two that will not work
with us what can we do
I'm so confused you're telling me for
nine months there was Zero jobs that
would hire you guys in the single
hottest job market in the history of US
of the United States I just don't buy it
Catherine I really want to believe you
how what happened
hey I called for advice not to be get
given a value well the advice is go to
work and you're telling me you can't
work what's that what I had a car
accident two years ago oh yeah I had a
car accident two years ago I'm not able
to enough as far as I'll go there and my
husband's in the tech industry
um and there's millions of people that
have been laid off in all of those
Industries uh he's looking for work
outside of his industry but I'm just
asking you what what would be possible
is are there any
um rules or laws or or considerations
for for a company uh that you owe money
to credit card so on that will not
um that will not allow you to make
arrangements no they they I mean they
they make arrangements when they think
they're not going to get paid and they
start to grasp what they've got what
they'll take what they can get
but they'll also sue you
because so we have every intention to
pay right along but of course but but
they're they're going to be thinking so
here's the deal
um they're going to be thinking the
exact same thing that George and I just
thought
and so I know there's going to be
extenuating circumstances there's going
to be hey what about this what about
this but their first question is going
to be our first question which is hey
George and I both have families if we
get laid off in our sector and there's
no job I'm gonna start mowing lawns and
I'm gonna start driving for Uber and I'm
gonna start driving for Amazon I know
you can't do that because you've got
some some
outside of the bell curve challenges but
what I'm saying is man they're just
going to say Hey you signed up for to
borrow money from us and you said you'd
pay us back in these time and we're
waiting for you to pay us back so I
don't know of any legal requirements for
any creditors to work with you outside
of like these special mandates like uh
the government made during covid
um like they can't evict you or they
can't do X Y and Z I don't know of
anything like that
I mean there's some things I can't do
legally like call you outside of certain
hours harass you things like that but
they're legally allowed to collect the
money and they can sue you for that
money and so you can tell them I'd be
proactive with them and say listen we
have no income right now we'd love to
pay you something we can't do that right
now how bad is the debt situation
um well we owe about 60 000 in debt and
uh or with various
companies including you know your car
payment and so on um and uh we're not
one to just buy buy we only have one car
at this point after the accident we did
not replace my car do they write you a
check
they paid off alone they did not it did
not cover our down that we paid on the
car okay um but it did cover up it did
Cover the loan uh so so so that was good
and we're renting and uh uh we started
something on the side here trying to be
proactive but my husband you know had a
really great job
um in his sector and I think age is part
of it uh he's 65 and plays a role and
there's all these um he interviews
really well he gets right to the top and
we think the Bean Counter says oh
there's a lot of people out there to
choose from so
um so we are being proactive and we have
put things in place to create something
on our own
um I was just wondering if there you
know if there's something you could say
to a creditors you know hey and we keep
saying we fully intend to pay we just
would like to pay a little less for uh
you know like four or five months or
something that's what we're asking yeah
if you've called and made that call and
asked them to work because I mean what
you're doing is you're appealing to
Grace will you please help us out and
they said well yes they've said no we
won't help you out and every one of them
is going to say well just don't pay the
others you pay us
and then the next one's gonna say well I
don't care about your car payment your
whatever payment you pay me because I
loaned you money and right so yeah it's
just going to go around it's going to go
around and around like that
um how short are you do you have any
income coming in whatsoever
Social Security okay
how much is that a month so we're we're
a couple thousand dollars short a month
how much is our social security every
month
so how are you covering the difference 4
500 4 500. okay and your expenses are
more than that
um our house which is a rental is 2500 a
month
is there anywhere cheaper you can move
an area
uh like a way like not in the Santa Fe
area
well we
let me rephrase that you can't afford to
live in Santa Fe yeah it is eating up
too much of the little income you guys
have right now and it's going to be
super hard to pay off debt when you know
60 70 of your income is going towards
housing here's my big fear Catherine is
that they're gonna come take your your
one car away
they're gonna repo it no we're not late
on anything yet do you have other debts
outside of the collections
um we're we're not in trouble yet we're
just trying to make arrangements and and
we and we know you know because we at
this point we we were really hoping with
all these interviews that got so far
with each one sure that we would have a
job at any time you know and that's
that's been since September so it's
become you know evident we have to do
something now can you guys can he go
drive for ubereats doordash deliver for
Amazon do anything
um he's applied actually for all those
types of places
um he's applied as a customer service
person at a at a Best Buy in ETC et
cetera but the fact that for nine months
no one has hired him I just can't
believe that in this job market even for
the side gig economy
well there's so many people that are out
of work we thought it wouldn't be an
issue and so when
I'm gonna have to go outside of my
industry and and he's he's not buying
steady for multiple jobs a day anything
that comes up and he's not and he's
gotten interviews and he even applies
for a manager at Billard you know
anything at all that he could use that
would that would just sustain us for
this period of time well he's it sounds
like he's Noble he's he's going down
swinging I think as George said the
harder conversation is because it may be
that Santa Fe that work is really tight
right now but it's bananas in other
markets it may be time to have a really
hard conversation about we can't afford
to live here right now and there is no
work